like let's talk about how she docks you
so when did it happen April 19th
um so I had like two two to three days
notice
um she was harassing me calling me
endlessly texting me emailing me anyone
who shared my last name so I I knew that
this was gonna happen I quickly went to
um a friend's home in the middle of
nowhere just in case anything happened I
was scared to be home
um and
yeah and then she she published my name
with an address
um
I mean it took me like a few days I was
kind of like just running on adrenaline
and then a few days later I it like hit
me what happened and
yeah I mean what specific questions do
you have well no I guess like the story
of like what happened when it all went
down what was the result of that like
what what kind of yeah so so look look
they published a story with a direct
link to a link and they also referenced
another website where they didn't link
it so it was two where people can go and
find another address and then removed
the link shortly after and then lied
saying they never did right but we never
did that no and I'm like there's an
archive showing you did no no no no what
was your experience immediately after
like in the 20 minutes after the post
went up did you start to have personal
experiences like people contact you and
stuff yeah oh my God my my phone was
blowing up like crazy it was probably
the most insane week of my life so far I
mean I'm pretty young but so far
um what I was gonna say it wasn't just
the address though it was your name my
name right my name all of a sudden
everybody knew that this account which
had people were threat like they want
they wanted to find out who you were
because as there were death threats and
then she facilitated the extremists who
were trying to find out who you were she
facilitated like for them I think yeah
that yeah that definitely but
immediately following it I think this
the thing that was the top of mind for
me was was what comes next right okay so
now everyone has my name my location so
what's gonna happen now are people going
to show up are there or is someone going
to come try to murder me or hurt me so
it was that unknown of what's gonna
happen and then the other thing keep in
mind is that no one knew what I looked
like there so that was the other thing
I'm like how long will it take for them
to find a picture and I waited that was
actually the most
it was actually it was really insecure
feeling because every day I'm like it's
taking into me the day that they found
that they released a picture they find
something or they show up to my house
and stalk me or I don't know and I
waited a week I waited two weeks I
waited a month two months it's been
eight months they never found a picture
yet and I mean now obviously I chose to
to reveal myself but
um that was it was every single time I
left my house I'm like is someone here
are they coming it's just the unknown so
I think that was that's what they want
right so when and and that's part of the
reason why I took that away from them by
showing myself I put that power away
from them when the Club Q thing happened
I said how do we stop the violence but
also stop these grooming events they
went nuts over this and I I people
calling my phone we got a ton of death
threats and they were explicitly saying
they want to make sure that people like
me you Matt Walsh and a few other people
like Andy know cannot live comfortably
and without Feeling Extreme they
outright say that yeah I know and it's
funny because I'm like dude like I
tweeted could you imagine some like
antifa soy boy showing up to the
mountains of West Virginia and tamaga
Country and then like breaking into a
house I'll tell you what happened uh
they got shot at and I don't want that
to happen it's scares me that one of our
guys you know opened fire and that
happened please do not come like don't
break into a property in West Virginia
For the Love of All That is Holy the
people in West Virginia
this is West Virginia man we're not
talking about we're not talking about
New Jersey we're not talking about New
York New York you're breaking the person
says please don't hurt me West Virginia
you you break through the window and
there's a right-wing nut job with it
with a Barrett M82 aimed right at you
and he's yelling Yee huh like the people
out here shooting their backyards for
fun so when people were doxing my
address
somehow
you know some people that's not my
address that's not where I live don't go
there someone's going to shoot you this
is insane one of the properties that we
have one it's my house I was not there
because we take precautions we set
things up I can't say too much because
it's security but we do these things not
too dissimilar to what Elon Musk does
with his plane to make sure it's hard to
find where I'm at someone thought they
found us
some things happened I can't say for
security reasons but lead us to believe
it was political
then I think it was it was three guys
but two guys had broken in there's a
third guy who I don't think was in the
house and
let's say shots were fired
and then they Dove out the window these
are the report that we got there's a
bullet hole I took a picture of it I
post I posted it they they think that by
doing these things and threatening us
I'm going to live in fear look I don't
know where you live I'm just gonna say
this
yeah I'm in West Virginia and I'm not
scared I'm scared for them I'm scared
for them please don't come here I will
not hesitate to you as far as if someone
comes to hurt me so I'll get that out
there too regarding I'm scared because
the people who live in in the mountains
out here
like these are the every house is a
trump flag on it every house is an fjb
ever ever look there are some like DC
liberal people who want to get out of
the big city and they come out here and
everyone just rolls their eyes at them
but we're talking about Farmland we're
talking about big big signs that people
make on their own saying like Trump
trump even to Santas I'm like antifa
comes out here someone's gonna make a
phone call and be like everybody
everybody come quick antifa's showing up
and then everyone's on their porch with
their guns like don't don't don't mess
around yeah I just I don't want people
to get hurt I strongly believe and I've
been saying this for months if they
would have the opportunity to kill us
me and you some you know many other
people with knowing that they're not
going to face any consequences they
would absolutely do it they would
absolutely take the shot I think they
tried to with Andy know
when they attack the reason that they
didn't come to First yeah is first of
all we have security but secondly
because they don't want to go to prison
most people right I don't think prison's
the issue these are collectivists they
they have powerful organizational
apparati or whatever whatever the word
is that will get them out organizations
will pay the bail we'll fight for them
the issue I think is truly opportunity
and the political ramifications these
activists know so let's let's talk about
Andy no Andy Noe is covering a protest
in Portland and they mercilessly beat
him leaving his his mouth bleeding his
ears bleeding it I believe they truly
wanted to kill him but it has to be a
random strike from a bunch of different
people
because if one person shows up with a
gun like Michael reinel did it is
condemned outright even the attack on
Andy know led to widespread political
Commendation even CNN briefly said it
was wrong that's a problem for political
ideologue collectivists who are trying
to win favor so they want to but it has
to be done in a way that doesn't hurt
their cause Michael reinel shot Aaron
Danielson twice in the chest and it was
bad for them that that's too it's it's
too much what they need is a false flag
what what James Lindsay's been calling a
drag Floyd uh so like they what they
need is for them to be the victim and
them to be attacked that's why I keep
telling people violence doesn't work
they're trying to trick you into using
it because then law enforcement can
respond with justification under under
the banner of Law and regular people
will be scared and sight against you
regarding like because I I think I think
really the goal of these of of activists
is to get you to stop whatever that
means and so regarding psychological
warfare which is basically what's been
happening with doxing and all that how
do you react when you feel that someone
is implementing psychological warfare on
you I completely ignore it I'll I'll
literally just tune it out and it takes
a it takes a lot of work to get to that
place where you could really do that but
I was telling Tucker on the show like I
it's totally just noise I completely
tune it out and I sleep really well at
night you got to do it you have to and I
think everyone with a big following and
and sort of prominence finds their own
strategy that works for them you
probably have your strategy for when
they really yeah
I always talk about there was there's
like they just make things up yeah
literally one of my favorites pizza box
thing like they'll just make stuff up
they claim someone actually posted on
Twitter that I showed up to their house
in Boston at 2AM and turned their TV on
while their friends and family were
sleeping and it woke everybody up and
and they're like wow I can't believe he
did so crazy that sounds just like
something he would do and I'm like did
no one find the story odd like they
didn't call some strange mans in my home
turn my TV on but people just need to
make things up and I believe it someone
posted on Twitter that so so Taylor
wrote an article that I used to be a
real estate agent in Brooklyn which is
true since I saw someone wrote on
Twitter that they remember working with
me once and I stole their clients from
them because I told their clients that
they shouldn't work with him because
he's gay and I hate gay people
that's what they said and obviously that
never happened completely made up I have
no idea what he's talking about but the
bigger aspect here to really consider
it's not just crazy people there's a lot
of crazy people out there but but these
are also powerful State institutions
that are going along with a lot of this
larger ideology of punishing people
censoring them de-platforming them uh
going out and and asking social media
companies to delete them because of the
ideas that they detest a lot of this for
me personally brings a lot of ethos of
Mao zedong's cultural revolution there's
a lot of things that happen then that I
think are very close to happening here I
don't think we're there yet but I think
we're definitely on a trajectory of
going there but this to me is just uh
you know very unsafe very insane and it
feels like we're down a path down to
Total political partisanship that
there's no going back from there's
nothing that could even bring us back
together where we could be one cohesive
Nation one cohesive people it feels like
this is the divide and conquer agenda
and the state has a particular victim
and it has a particular Victor already
picked out thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time